bring your own phone.
That Matter
>> WE HAVE LAWS THAT ARE THE
WORST ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD AS
COMING IN, WITH THAT THAT BEING
SAID WE ARE DOWN OVER 40% ON
BORDER CROSSINGS.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO WHAT I
THINK NOBODY ELSE HAS BEEN ABLE
TO DO.
>> Laura: THAT WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKING ABOUT
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION CRISIS
BUT THERE IS SOMETHING YOU DON'T
OFTEN HEAR ABOUT, ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION CRISIS THANKS TO
CHAIN MIGRATION.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS RELEASED
FIGURES SHOWING THAT CHAIN
MIGRATION, CHECK THIS OUT, IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR 7.8 MILLION
IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE COME TO THE
UNITED STATES IN THE LAST
DECADE.
THAT'S THE SIZE OF
NEW YORK CITY.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF ROUGHLY
10.8 MILLION IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE
COME HERE SINCE 2008.
CHAIN MIGRATION ALLOWS NEWLY
NATURALIZED CITIZENS TO BRING IN
ESSENTIALLY UNLIMITED NUMBER OF
FOREIGN RELATIVES TO THE
COUNTRY, EVEN OFTEN DISTANT
RELATIVES.
HERE TO DISCUSS THIS IS ACTING
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF U.S.
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANKS FOR BEING IN HERE
TONIGHT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Laura: WE HEAR A LOT ABOUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION BUT THAT
PART OF THE IMMIGRATION QUESTION
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE FORGET
ABOUT, THAT WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WANTED TO DO
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING AS WELL
AS ENFORCE THE BORDER WE ARE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT, IS TO HAVE
SENSIBLE LEGAL IMMIGRATION
POLICIES THAT BRING IN PEOPLE
THAT CAN REALLY ADD VALUE TO OUR
COUNTRY.
>> HE CERTAINLY RENEWED THE
SPIRIT OF THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT AT CDP FOR US TO DO
MORE ON THE BORDER.
THERE IS A GENEROUS IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM BUT WE NEED TO DO MORE ON
THE BORDER AND HE HAS ASKED ALSO
FOR THE LOOPHOLES TO BE CLOSED.
THOSE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO SEE GET
DONE.
>> Laura: THE ASYLUM FRAUD,
HOW IMPORTANT WITH THAT BEFORE
YOU AND THE MEN AND WOMEN ON THE
FRONT LINES DOING THIS JOB EVERY
DAY TO GET THAT ASYLUM, THE
LOOPHOLES IN THAT SYSTEM THAT
ALLOWS SO MANY PEOPLE TO COME IN
NOW AND THEN JUST FRANKLY,
SADLY, DISAPPEAR.
>> WE HAVE TO GET TO A PLACE
WHERE IF THEY HAVE TO PROCESS
THEY HAVE THAT WHILE THEY ARE
STILL IN CUSTODY SO THEY ARE NOT
ABUSING THE SYSTEM.
>> Laura: SO IN OTHER WORDS
THEY DON'T FULLY AND NEVER SHOW
UP FOR THE HEARING WHICH IS WHAT
THEY OFTEN DO.
>> WE CAN DO MORE ON THE BORDER.
WE ARE DOING BETTER ON THE
BORDER.
WITH THIS PRESIDENT WE HAVE A
NEW WALL GOING IN.
WE HAVE THE NATIONAL GUARD
DEPLOYMENTS.
>> Laura: TELL US ABOUT THE
WALL.
I HEAR CONFLICTING THINGS ABOUT
THE WALL.
WE HEARD THAT OMNIBUS FUND OF
THE WALL BUT THEN WE HEARD IT
ACTUALLY DIDN'T FIND THE WALL
AND THE PRESIDENT WASN'T TOLD
THE TRUTH ABOUT THAT, CERTAINLY
NOT THE WALL THAT HE WANTS.
>> WE ARE INSTALLING THE WALL
RIGHT NOW WHICH IS REPLACING THE
FENCE THAT WAS ON THE BOARD AND
OUT.
WE HAVE NEW CAPABILITY GOING IN
THERE.
NEW CAPABILITY IN SANTA TERESA
NEW MEXICO.
WE HAVE PROJECTS AND PLANNING
UNDERWAY FOR SOUTH TEXAS AND
SAN DIEGO FOR REPLACEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA.
ALL OF THOSE ARE GOING TO BE
IMPROVED CONDITIONS FOR OUR
AGENTS TO WORK IN, SAFER BORDER
ENVIRONMENT AND WORK TECHNOLOGY
TO GO ALONG WITH IT.
>> Laura: I HAD OVER THE YEARS
INTERVIEWED SO MANY BORDER
PATROL AGENTS AND CUSTOMS AGENTS
WHO WERE SO DEMORALIZED BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO DO THEIR JOB AND
THEY FELT LIKE, I'M NOT TRYING
TO GET POLITICAL HERE, BUT UNDER
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION THEY
WERE KIND OF BEING HELD BACK OR
EVEN SOMETIMES VILIFIED UNFAIRLY
EVEN SOMETIMES VILIFIED UNFAIRL
UNFAIRLY.
TELL ME ABOUT JUST THE
GENERAL -- YOU REFERENCED IT
BRIEFLY, BUT THE GENERAL MOOD OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO DO THIS
JOB AND OFTEN TIMES IT IS NOT A
SAFE JOB, IT IS VERY DIFFICULT.
>> THEY TAKE ENORMOUS RISKS AND
THEY WANT TO BE SUCCESSFUL SO
THE RENEWED FOCUS ON BORDER
SECURITY HAS BEEN VERY IMPORTANT
FOR US.
ADDING CAPABILITIES, DOING
BETTER, DOING THEM IN A SAFER
ENVIRONMENT AND GIVING THEM WHAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT, THEY
WANT A SAFER BORDER AND NOW WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY WITH THIS
PRESIDENT TO TRY TO GET MORE OF
THAT CAPABILITY DOWN THERE SO
THAT WE CAN DO OUR JOBS.
>> Laura: TELL ME WHAT YOU ALL
NEED CONGRESS TO DO.
YOU HAVE REPUBLICANS IN CHARGE
OF THE HOUSE, REPUBLICANS IN
CHARGE OF THE SENATE AND A
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT WHO MADE
BORDER ENFORCEMENT A PRIMARY
FOCUS OF HIS ADMINISTRATION.
>> WE WANTED TO PRIORITIZE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE CAN ADD
CAPABILITIES.
WE ARE TRYING TO HIRE AGENTS, WE
NEED TO DO THAT AND WE ALSO NEED
TO CLOSE THE LOOP PULSE.
WE NEED THE LOOP TO BE CLOSED ON
THE ASYLUM SYSTEM.
WE NEED TO HAVE A WEIGHT OF HOLD
PEOPLE WHEN THEY COME INTO THE
COUNTRY UNTIL THEIR TIME TO BE
REMOVED ONCE THEY HAVE THE DUE
PROCESS.
IF WE CAN DO ALL OF THOSE THINGS
AT THE SAME TIME WE WILL HAVE A
MUCH SAFER BORDER.
FEWER PEOPLE WILL TRY TO TAKE
THAT DANGEROUS JOURNEY.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE ASKING.
>> Laura: WE HAVE PEOPLE IN
CONGRESS NOW, MOSTLY MORE
MODERATE LIBERAL REPUBLICANS
TRYING TO PUSH A NEW AMNESTY
THEY CALL IT, A TECHNICAL WAY OF
GETTING A LOT OF BILLS ON THE
FLOOR.
WE DON'T HAVE TO GO INTO IT, BUT
WOULD AMNESTY OR DANGLING THE
PROSPECT OF AMNESTY AT THIS
POINT AS WE APPROACH THE SUMMER
MONTHS, WITH THAT MAKE YOUR JOB
EASIER OR MORE DIFFICULT GIMMICK
>> I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
>> Laura: WHICH ONE GIMMICK
EASIER OR MORE DIFFICULT GIMMICK
>> I DON'T THINK IT WOULD MAKE
IT EASIER.
>> Laura: IT WOULD MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT, WOULD IT NOT
LIKE THE SUMMER OF 2014      201
LIKE THE SUMMER OF 2014      204
LIKE THE SUMMER OF 2014      20W
LIKE THE SUMMER OF 2014      20T
LIKE THE SUMMER OF 2014      20H
LIKE THE SUMMER OF 2014      20E
POSSIBILITY OF AMNESTY AND THERE
WAS A BIG WAVE OF UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS CROSSING THE BORDER.
>> CLOSING THE LOOPHOLES AND
ADDING THE CAPABILITY, BORDER
LAW, THE NATIONAL GUARD, GIVING
US MORE TECHNOLOGY ON THE
BORDER, HIRING AGENTS, THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED.
>> Laura: HOW ABOUT THE
PROSECUTORS AT THE BORDER,
IMMIGRATION JUDGES DOWN THERE.
AGAIN, THEY HAVE LIKE 6,000 MORE
PERSONNEL I BELIEVE, IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS AND JUDGES DOWN THERE,
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT I
BELIEVE IS GETTING.
BUT WE HAVE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE CROSSING IN A 3-4 WEEK
PERIOD.
YOU NEED MORE THAN THAT, DO YOU
NOT?
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
STEPPING UP.
THEY ARE ADDING RESOURCES.
THE SECRETARY HAS DIRECTED US TO
REFER ALL PEOPLE WHO CROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY FOR PROSECUTION
AND SO WE ARE STARTING TO RAMP
UP THOSE CAPABILITIES AS WELL.
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED OVER THE
YEARS IS THE CONSEQUENCES OF
PEOPLE DOING ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES.
>> Laura: HEAVEN FORBID YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE CONSEQUENCES FOR
ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
KEEP US UPDATED BECAUSE I THINK
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO HEAR